ich denke ich muss immer geraten wobei
immer viele macher denken geben wieso
also jetzt grad also bald liegen
wer auf der rennstrecke des lebens zu
früh bremst verliert
josef ried gibt gas warum er damit immer
wieder aneckt davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
der berg das wahrzeichen von zürich eine
national geschützte landschaft eine
autofreie grüne oase ausgerechnet hier
thront das lebenswerk von josef reh
hirsch ufer sein hotel betrieben mit 55
zimmern helly landeplatz und eigenem
aussichtsturm
[Musik]
der uetliberg gehört jetzt zu den zehn
beliebtesten ausflugszielen der schweiz
mit zehntausenden besuchern pro jahr um
seine ideen zu verwirklichen hat free
viel geld und herzblut investiert
foto bes was wir brauchten diese geilste
musste ich ja wenn man auf dem bett in
der cdu war speziell
das tut ja eher mäßig das bett ist auch
übergroß herzförmige badewanne auf dem
mittelberg steht suzuki und das scharfer
beobachtung der naturschützer weil er
die gesetze allzu locker interpretierte
musste er in den vergangenen jahren
bereits eine gartenwirtschaft abbrechen
und einen verpflegungs floss
fri bestreitet nicht dass rees mittelbau
gesetzen nicht immer so genau nimmt die
verstaubt nur stehe er unter besonderer
beobachtung und schließlich sei die
bürokratie der reine horror
was da wirklich interessante unter dem
turm vorhin schon kiosk vor 40 jahren
davon platzt und kiosk antritt 2014 darf
das kufsteiner führung laufen wenn wir
wenn man dass das ganze keine
vorstellung gesagt die schweiz überhaupt
denkbar ist gestoppt aber vom turm
jetzt streitet sich der hotelier darum
ob seine wintergärten in denen er bei
schlechtem wetter mehrere hundert gäste
bewirken kann legal sind oder nicht der
bewegung von 2001 wenn man die größte
sondersteuer bewilligt kaufen was als
einzelner großer ein stück sondersteuer
auf der terrasse da genau die größe was
jetzt ist einmal bewilligt um das ganze
keinen sonderstatus
bis zum start über zeigen dass kaloff
tun
darüber laufen ja
sauerstoff blockiert
er spannte wie auch immer das
bundesgericht sieht es anders
es hat entschieden dass free abbrechen
muss es ist ein bisher schlimmste
rückschlag
er wird in zwei millionen umsatz kosten
trotzdem scheinen dass sie nicht allzu
sehr zu beeindrucken abbauen urteilen
oder überdachte terrasse blieb das nur
kleine teile von ganz große wunderschöne
hottenrott oberhand
fri geht zum gegenangriff über sofort
nach dem entscheid hatte die presse
eingeladen um über neue pläne zu
sprechen also unternehmer viktor und der
unterkommission türe nicht nur die
terrasse war irgendwie ist die terrasse
die blieb das ohne terrasse muss da
immer die schönste terrasse verliert man
auch im winter sogar von dc ist der sich
alle die 100 arbeitsplätze ganz sicher
mit andere ideen und andere projekt
schönes wochenende
ibm gehört und gleichzeitig dass der
entscheid knapp über der terrasse
überraschung sieht es so schnell
gerechnet dass das irgendwann kommt und
damit teile das idm lauf so weiter wie
bis anhin hat somit besteht ist im
januar ungefähr und damit sie
abgebrochen
also mich selig zu sich kein mitarbeiter
muss entlang sondern sie eher
lösungssuche für alle
das war wieder da und wir geben nicht
auf
wer noch fragen
kai ich klar ist klar die analoge welt
sowie deine farbe im gesicht
[Gelächter]
russikon salopp sein
doch seine mitarbeiter arbeiten gerne
und oftmals schon seit jahren für ihn
auf dem uetliberg gab es schon vor 100
jahren ein gran hotel mit direkten
zugsverbindungen london
udo kulm free findet auf dem gipfel
solle der tourismus blühen rundherum die
natur doch irgendwie lässt sich das
nicht immer auseinanderhalten
es ist der erste august free erwartet
einen ansturm von ausflügen und plant
ein großes feuerwerk mit beschallung das
erste mal mit musik über alles bescheid
ganz platz und das ist ja mal eine
andere haben es gepackt
ich habe viel gemacht mit dem herrschen
august auf den uetliberg kommen die
gäste mit dem zug das gepäck mit dem
elektromobil das fahrverbot für autos
ist heilig theoretisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo dann haben wir kennen sie das
schild nicht kann ich ihr nicht packen
das ist schickte verboten
aber so ist nur schwierig
ja ja die psi und wenn ja wie viel
passiert also haltbare der woche wurde
darüber verlieren
gut so wieder rein
oder laut autos sind nicht erlaubt zu
verbieten
new dawns hier haben sie das schild
nicht gesehen noch nicht geschaut ob sie
müssen schauen aufgabe als josef ried
das uto kulm als geschäftsführer
übernahm hatte es zehn mitarbeiter
privat 23 jahre alt und kam ohne einen
franken in der tasche nach zürich in der
nähe von diesen teams im kanton
graubünden wuchs friauf als ältester von
sechs geschwistern einer
bergbauernfamilie zwei drei mal pro jahr
kehrte zurück in die heimat
am straßenrand steht der star seiner
familie fries jüngerer bruder bestreitet
sein leben aus bauer wie eh und je
schon als er fünf jahre alt war musste
free auf dem hof des vaters mithelfen
aber im unterschied zu seinem bruder hat
er ihn vor einer 30 jahren verlassen
viele worte verlieren die brüder nicht
darüber wagte sich sowieso aber er hat
die srg am haus oder das wird noch mal
mutter zu verdienen
[Applaus]
ja ich habe auch lieber autos herum in
der unterhaltung von ein herz und die
auch die landwirtschaftszone sowie
direkt in der app verbuchen so unrecht
hat der nutzer und so ist werde ich noch
zwei wochen sommerferien zum heurigen
also in kairo
[Musik]
noch immer steht fliesst elternhaus im
dorf kompanie aus dass damals nicht mehr
als ein paar dutzend einwohner hatte die
einfachen verhältnisse und die enge des
dorflebens wurde er so schnell wie
möglich hinter sich lassen
eine lehre als koch in diesen tisch
wurde sein sprungbrett
die hauptstadt war das erste gebiet um
zwei touristen und so weiter und können
darauf dass dieser dialog treten und
noch mal wir haben als team noch kann
und wie ist der tiger
ich fühle mich eigentlich fällt ja ich
also aufgegangen
eigentlich spricht free nicht besonders
gerne über sich aber er ist
einverstanden dass wir seinen ehemaligen
sekundarlehrer treffen um mehr über ihn
zu erfahren
frank du siehst ja immer noch gleich aus
naja nicht ganz
aber du bist gewachsen die breite
vielleicht aber jetzt ist ja wenn's
hauptunternehmer willst du mit mir
gesagt
und das ist so schön franz man erinnert
sich an einem aufsatz in dem schrieb der
vater habe so viel am hals und keine
zeit für ihn den ganzen tag freuen und
am ende vor einem kleinen hafen gras
stehen das kommt es nicht sein für den
sohn berechnend einkalkulieren
ich bin immer hat und praktischen
praktika sie immer schauen schon also
wir wollen in die fahrbahn dann wirst du
mithelfe 6 im steinofen land und feldern
an ihm sorgen dass sie kann mit
maschinen um attraktive und die auch so
wenig wie möglich vorhanden so schnell
wie möglich lernen mit dem blöden rapid
dahin wird eine steile hänge und an dass
sie das im griff haben und kann immer
mit einer maschine dann könne nur
funktionieren und es hat mir viel spaß
gemacht da vorhanden wäre
und so gelang es zu fliehen nach einigen
jahren als geschäftsführer auf dem
uetliberg mit harter arbeit und kalkül
denn udo korn zu kaufen
seither ist der gipfel des wittenberg
sein privatbesitz 27.000 quadratmeter
so einmalig damit hat auch ein
druckmittel in der hand denn wenn er
wollte könnte er alles verkaufen
ob dann noch tourismus möglich wäre ist
offen der mit dem verkauf ist wie vor
bis vor zwei ist das thema sie das
vergessen und verkäufen aber jetzt grund
für die situation warum ich jetzt
glücklich also wirklich diese kastriert
ist es kalt und vor ort
aber wenn ich jetzt da wirklich zwei
aufzug wird oder und nicht schätzt dass
das giftigste ziel ist es mittelfristig
sind schon da wenn ein kollege von mir
langsam vorherbestimmt du nicht noch mal
so lang studieren kauft oder ruß und
sauber zu machen und sonst mit dem
auslassen das denn dort die grünen mit
dem umschlag ganze show geboten
das gibt pro interessiert die streuung
über konkret konkrete sehr schwer wenn
das zeigt nur dass eventuell realisieren
und da kann ich keine zahlen aber sich
im zweistelligen millionenbereich
das ist es auch
in einer höheren zweistelligen
millionenbereich
also der königsfamilie leider war die
zeit natürlich wurde die bank zum das
ganze finanzieren sonst kann man das
nicht machen
sicher ist josef ries geschäft läuft am
abend des ersten august strömen die
leute in scharen auf den berg vier
monate bevor die terrasse abgebrochen
wird führt für seine gäste zum barbecue
plage
und auf dem vorplatz gibt es grillwürste
an mobilen ständen
das wäre zwar genau hin um nicht erlaubt
aber wer will schon einen fahrgast ohne
bratwurst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die drohnen
also wenn ich das sehen wir müssen sagen
berichten möchte gehöre ja eine sache
ist die wenn die anderen schlafen oder
muss ich bis zum auch halten
[Musik]
ja und
im dezember wird josef friese eine
terrasse abbrechen
ein kleiner rückschlag auf der
rennstrecke des unternehmer lebens
[Musik]
wenn er über sein hobby spricht spürt
waren dass sie sie nicht ganz kalt lässt
[Musik]
was soll ich machen teilt sich das kann
man komplett abschalten weil ich sehe
wie die heiler darauf konzentrieren
wollte
doch die benzin getankt und whitney
gestank und dumm nur dass sind gerade
hier die realität einholt sein ferrari
ist zu laut
er muss zurück in die box
[Musik]
die solcherlei auf der rennstrecke das
problem ja aus dem man das thema
verbrauch immer warum sind erheben
anspruch dieser günstiges grundstück
erwerben kann man dem flugplatz war
flug wird nicht möglich sein das thema
und günstig unter druck auf
internationale soldaten haben sind wir
auch das lieblingslied mich darauf mit
ihr geredet und 26
so sorgt die dakar ärmer machen ja das
institut aber das können wir schon und
so vermutlich von geoffrey wird auch
weiterhin zu hören sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]